رعب في امريكا فطر نادر مقاوم للعقاقير قد
يكون مميتا وينتشر بسرعه في انحاء
الولايات المتحده تحضيرات اطلقها مسؤولون
بعد دراسه بحثيه حكوميه اوضحت ان فكره
كانديدا اوريس الذي يعرف ايضا بفطر داء
البقع البيضاء بات يهدد حياه الالاف في
البلاد وينتشر بكثره في المراكز الصحيه
فما هذا الفطر وما هي اعراضه
كانديدا اوريس بترول مايكروبيون ينتقل من
خلال العدوى بين البشر واكتشف لاول مره في
اذن مريض ياباني عام 2009 ومن اعراضه
الاكثر شيوعا الحمى والقشعريره وقع بيضاء
مؤلمه داخل الفم تشققات في زوايا الفم
مراكز السيطره على الامراض والوقايه قالت
ان نحو 33% من المصابين بهذا الفطر يموتون
فيما تعمل شركات ادويه على تطوير عقار
لمحاربه الفطر القاتل